on Monday HBO is premiering a new series
White House plumbers which focuses on
men Whose actions inadvertently toppled
the president they were trying to help
re-elect CBS News Chief election and
campaign correspondent Robert Costa
recently caught up with actor Justin
Thoreau who portrays the infamous G
Gordon Liddy
God and the American people have been
damn good to me and I'm damn grateful if
it's about Watergate or anything else I
don't care I'm happy when he died two
years ago at age 90 Watergate operative
G Gordon Liddy was described by The
Washington Post as a man with an intense
stare Cannonball head bristling mustache
and machine gun style of speaking the
look of an archetypal bad guy stand up
and raise your right hand Now 50 years
after the Watergate hearings dominated
American television in 1973. well you'll
be talking to the hearing
he has no comment this Infamous American
character is having a comeback of sorts
shoulders back shoulders back relaxed
he's always grinning Lydia's always
grinning always happen but he is kind of
uh you know you can bleep this out but
he's a bit of a pig in these moments
he's trolling he's the original troll
actor Justin Thoreau plays Liddy in
HBO's new limited series White House
plumbers you should have seen this guy
operate it's the cleaning lady to let us
in it's a satirical ROM through the
lives of the bungaling oddballs who
tried to save then helped end Richard
Nixon's presidency they are trying to
break us it's also a fresh take on the
memory of Watergate in Hollywood where
so often Nixon and the reporters who
broke the story have been front and
center I wish you can't tell me about
deep throat do you feel like 50 years
after Watergate the burglars are finally
getting their due yeah I mean we all
know obviously the the you know Woodward
and Bernstein side of the story the
story of dog and journalism and then you
know risky choices taken by an editor at
the Washington Post but the actual meat
and potatoes of the reason the actual
gate that started all the other Gates
um is this story president he's a good
man
between you and me I worry about some of
the people with whom he surrounds
himself
Woody Harrelson plays lidy's partner in
crime e Howard hunt you are not a
federal agent
and an intelligence agent
you are a spy hunt and Lady are enlisted
what do you need
I want you to meet Gordon Liddy toughest
guy I know to stop government insiders
from leaking State Secrets like the
Pentagon papers with the Press
plumbers
they fix leaks
oh but things quickly escalate we now
work for the committee to re-elect the
president and the series captures the
pride and vanity of the dirty tricksters
who would make one mistake after another
it's a double-sided deadbolt unbeknownst
to me there were four break-ins you know
or four break-in attempts you know it
was only the fourth one where they
actually got in and you'd think by the
second or maybe the third one I might
have gone you know maybe this isn't a
great idea but they were sort of pretty
dogged that scene in the show which
comes right from real life where Lydia
puts his hand above the flame and never
moves it and there's no trick I do not
Bend and I do not break what's the trick
there's no trick he just burns himself I
mean it's just the guy who can put a
cigarette out on his face if he wanted
to according to the investigators report
Lydia and Hunt left that room when the
break-in was discovered the bond between
Lydia and Hunt is complicated both
political schemers and True Believers
but with differences in class education
and style it is classic political
Bromance they got together they worked
together I think they were in line with
each other and then once things started
to go south they started to fall out of
love with each other and and eventually
ended up never speaking again I have
such a different unwater gaity
relationship with this city I'm just I
you know I was a kid when I grew up here
your mom worked for the Washington Post
it's right for the style section she was
an essayist but she covered the
Georgetown set yeah yeah yeah she um you
know I'm sure she uh you know went to a
couple dinner parties down here
the cast recent press tour took them
through Washington D.C the rose mother
and father were on hand along with
Beltway luminaries including Bob
Woodward did you trade any Lydia's
stories actually I was trying to like I
went up I saw him right after it and he
went oh hey how you doing and then he
saw Woody and it was like hey Woody and
then he started laying in the wood ago
like you know let me tell you about
lyddie Lydia was and I was kind of like
listening again I think maybe I'd like
to believe maybe he didn't recognize me
with my beard maybe you should have kept
the mustache yeah exactly by the end of
Watergate Nixon stepped down I shall
resign the presidency effective at noon
tomorrow and many aides would go to
prison including Liddy he liked being
one of the President's Men he liked
being this sort of soldier lydie spent
just over four years in prison upon his
release he embraced his infamy writing a
bestseller working the lecture and talk
show circuit even appearing on an
episode of the 1980s crime drama Miami
Vice
[Music]
CBS News spoke with lyddie in 1993. what
do I care about 20 years ago you know I
don't sit around playing old tapes by
that time lyddie had built a following
on conservative radio it's got kind of a
great voice for radio he speaks kind of
like he's like a G-Man you know like yes
here's the thing we're going to take a
minute on the station or we're going to
do you know like there's a kind of um
that's exactly what he's you know what I
mean do they think that they're going to
be any uh more dead because it was
semi-automatic and not a revolver
revolver
he's such a strange person a character
in American history you know America
makes many unique Americans just
incredible eccentric characters and he
is one of them he's just like yeah I did
that thing and I'm proud of it because I
was it was the right thing to do they
believed yeah true believers you know he
considered himself a true true patriot
for CBS Saturday morning Robert Costa
Washington
classic voice Dragon I like them yeah I
was talking about like yeah the revolver
I want to see that by the way yeah
looking good really good